Now, we know that there's no way
we're going to be able to fit a tree
to a non-additive matrix, by definition
of what a non-additive matrix is. But
maybe we can construct a tree that is,
in a sense,
the best approximate solution for
a given distance matrix.
For example, consider
the non-additive distance matrix that
we encountered earlier in the talk, shown
below, along with the following tree.
To measure how close this tree
is to the distance matrix,
we need to compare the entries in D,
i.e., upper case D,
with the distance between
the corresponding leaves in the tree,
i.e., lower case d.
The matrices are symmetric, so
we only need to consider the entries
above the main diagonal, of course.
Now for this example,
notice that the red values disagree
between the matrix and the tree.
The distance from i to l, for example, is 3,
not 4, which is what the tree indicates.
And the distance from j to l is 5,
So in general we can compute how well
a tree fits a distance matrix by computing
the sum of squared errors between
the distance matrix, upper case D,
and the distances between leaves in
the tree that we're given, lower case d.
So to denote this sum of squared errors,
we used the term "Discrepancy(T, D)".
For this particular tree, there
are only two non-zero errors,
both of which are equal to 1, and
so the discrepancy is equal to 2.
However, this is not the best we can do for
this tree.
Why don't you take a moment to see if
you can find edge weights that provide
a smaller value of discrepancy?
Can you find maybe a provably best
assignment of edge weights for this tree?
In general, there is a polynomial
algorithm that will minimize the sum of
squared errors if we are given the
structure of the tree (T) in advance,
but in practice, we're not going to know
the structure of the tree in advance,
so we'll need to minimize the sum of squared
errors over all possible tree structures.
The number of tree structures is
exponential in the number of the leaves in
the tree, and so unfortunately, this least
squares distance based phylogeny problem
is NP-complete, and so
it's not going to help us fit a tree
to a non-additive matrix unfortunately.